voir le livre vous en pensez quoi de ce
livre je suis très fier de mes élèves
oui cent vingt élèves qui ont travaillé
sur le projet durant les trois années
très contente que ça puisse aboutir
puis qu'ils aient travaillé à leur
niveau certains ont fait de nombreuses
biographies 5,6 cette biographie
d'autres un petit peu moins certains ont
fait des dessins des lettres fictives
donc c'est formidable d'arriver à a
concentré tout ça dans un livre je suis
très contente que ça leur plaise puis
contente d'avoir abouti ou et vous êtes
contente du résultat
tout à fait oui très bien en tant que
prof d'histoire-géo travailler sur un
projet comme ça c'est quoi l'objectif au
départ
au départ c'est pouvoir en fait
repéré ce qu'on vous voit en classe dans
le court dans un cours un peu magistral
et puis de travail et donc de façon
concrète avec des soldats des soldats
qu'habite dans notre rue qu'habiter dans
notre rue habitait dans nos eaux dans
les villages autour de comparé liés et
puis des élèves s'identifie donc ça
c'est important parce que ça c'est
concret mais parce que quand on dit la
guerre de 14-18 c'est un million quatre
cent mille morts côté français savaient
pas dire grand chose
non tout à fait à l'ordre pour les
élèves c'est du concret c'est voir
qu'ils mangeaient les mêmes choses que
nous aujourd'hui manger du fromage font
les fous du chocolat suisse
et puis puis voilà des jeunes qui
meurent à 22 ans 25 ans donc c'est vrai
pour les élèves ça leur permet de
mémoriser davantage parce que quand on
fait quelque chose on mémorise beaucoup
plus que quand on entend là vous avez
entendu ce qui lui ce qu'ils retiennent
de cette expérience vous en dites quoi
de ce qu'ils ont retenu c'est formidable
et lis des choses formidables
donc par rapport par rapport à l'hommage
le respect vis-à-vis des soldats
c'est vrai que je suis un petit peu
surprise parce que je me dis c'est loin
ça fait un siècle
mais non non en fait
et ils sont encore très respectueux les
élèves et puis
très respectueux de ses soldats morts
pour la france certains seraient prêts
encore à partir pour pour la patrie donc
je trouve ça beau et puis je me rends
compte aussi que des élèves sont très
sensibles ressentent beaucoup d'émotion
quand on parle de cette période là
d'ailleurs quand on était à verdun les
élèves pleurait des élèves tombent et
avait avait fait des malaises parce que
justement il y avait de la fatigue c'est
vrai qu'on part à deux heures du matin
quand on part à verdun c'est loin il ya
de la fatigue mais il ya toute cette
émotion ou s'il sait c'est beau de les
voir comme ça aussi s'entend après oui